I think sports writing is a magnificent
literature you even get non sports
writers writing about it you ever read
Gatsby there is a portion in there that
refers to the 1919 Black Sox scandal
where manheimer I think his name is her
some heimer is talking to Gatsby in a
bar you get Arthur Conan Doyle wrote
books on boxing Jack London wrote boxing
I can go Paul Gallico it was a sports
editor at The New York Daily News wrote
the Poseidon Adventure so you get
crossovers all over the place yes we're
labeled sports writers but we really are
just writers and half of us will write
on bathroom walls and lipstick of it
pays women's rooms with two hands
great can you talk a little bit about
your about your method how do you so
you're covering sports how do you do you
take notes while you're watching a game
or do you know let it seep into memory
and then how do you shave that into the
pieces afterward well you give it some I
think red Smith said it best he said mmm
you first cut your wrist then you bleed
on the paper then you're right you're
looking for the lead you're looking for
a storyline you're looking for
personalities who did this you just
don't write for home runs were hit today
and they want ten to nine okay great
what I mean what went into that I went
to a fight last weekend mayweather
mosley and in the introduction at the
press conference two days before
mayweather was introduced as the
undivided feeder which is a spoonerism
there was a reverend william Spooner in
england at Oxford who did everything
bass ackwards he would say things like
instead of conquering Kings take their
titles which is a him he'd introduce it
as tinkering kong's take their title or
talking about at the end of World War
one the troops would come home and quote
instead of the flags would be hung in
tribute he said the hags would be formed
he did everything bass ackwards and
changing the sounds of the first words
in succession so I wrote a whole piece
almost like that on the fight not easy
but keeping in sort of the mood and the
Flair of what I picked up it might be
fun for people it might not it was fun
for me and I get the biggest kick out of
writing and having fun with it I
remember one line I had that was fun to
get somebody into
story because you like to get a hook and
there was a no hitter thrown and I'm
writing about it and I started with it
was as unbelievable as Santa Claus
suffering vertigo comma Captain Bligh
seasickness comma Mary having a little
lamb period the it was and then I went
on to tell it well I'd either scared the
hell out of readers and they've gone
elsewhere or I've hooked them you'd look
for that I have one friend who'll go
unnamed great sports writer I remember
he was walking around the press box one
day reading everybody's lead that's good
that's good he was looking for his own
really much but you know you're looking
for a lead and they're not easy to come
by